FRANK: While Mike and Dani are
out on the East Coast picking,
she texts us a lead
in South Dakota.
We're gonna meet up with Adam
and his dad, Bruce.
FRANK: Their family has lived
on the farm since the '40s,
and the house and the barns
have accumulations
of everything from
petroliana to toys!
ROBBIE: Man!
FRANK: That's what
I'm talking about.
That's my whole world!
ROBBIE: Yeah!
I'm excited.
[honks horn]
FRANK: You must be Bruce.
ADAM: Nope, I'm Adam.
FRANK: Oh, you're Adam?
Alright.
Frank.
ADAM: Nice to meet ya.
ROBBIE: Robbie, nice to see ya.
FRANK: You talked
to Danielle on the phone?
ADAM: Yes, I did.
Just let me go get the old man,
and I'll introduce you guys.
FRANK: Alright, great.
ADAM: Hey, Pops!
BRUCE: Yeah.
ADAM: Yeah, them guys are here.
BRUCE: Okay.
Well, hey, guys.
ROBBIE: Man, you look exactly
like-- look at you two.
You look exactly alike.
FRANK: Alike.
ROBBIE: Holy cow!
How you doing?
Rob; nice to meet ya.
BRUCE: Pretty good.
Nice to meet you, Rob.
FRANK: Nice to meet you, Bruce;
Frank.
BRUCE: Nice to meet you, Frank.
FRANK: Sounds like you want
to thin out a little bit.
BRUCE: Well, we got
a few things here,
and we can go look around,
see if anything
tickles your fancy on it.
ROBBIE: Alright, yeah.
ROBBIE: I'm getting excited.
There's six or seven
buildings here.
BRUCE: I have been
here my whole life.
I'm 61 years old.
FRANK: Okay.
BRUCE: Growing up here on
the farm, it was just kind of
exciting to go out
and help in the fieldwork.
Before I went
into grade school,
I was driving tractors
around the farm already.
ROBBIE: What do you guys
farm around here?
BRUCE: Corn or soybeans,
usually.
Sometimes wheat.
BRUCE: Dad did a lot of service
station work in here.
BRUCE: My dad had
a small shop here
that he did a lot of fixing,
repairing for neighbours.
The age that my parents
grew up in, they pretty much...
kept everything.
They didn't get rid of
much of anything.
ROBBIE: When you're picking
an accumulation of, like,
three generations on
a multi-generational farm,
there's a lot of stuff
that gets left behind
that never got cleaned up.
We have to work
a little bit harder
to find the good stuff here.
FRANK: Got some of
these Co-op cans here.
BRUCE: Yep.
FRANK: I got six of 'em.
15 bucks apiece.
That'd be $90.
BRUCE: That'll work.
FRANK: Alright,
I'm gonna keep looking.
FRANK: Republic
Steel Corporation.
I like old boxes.
20 bucks.
BRUCE: How about 30 on it?
FRANK: I'll split it with you.
25.
BRUCE: That'll work.
I'm good with that.
FRANK: Alright.
We got a deal.
BRUCE: Thank you.
FRANK: Alright.
ROBBIE: Frank.
FRANK: What d'you see?
ROBBIE: Stained glass.
FRANK: This
came out of a house.
It needed to be rescued.
How about $65?
BRUCE: What do you think 75?
FRANK: I'll split it with you.
70.
BRUCE: Okay.
That'll work.
FRANK: Alright, you got a deal.
Great.
FRANK: Today was
the kind of day I love.
We got to hang out
with some cool people;
we got to buy
some neat stuff.
ROBBIE: I got it; you got it?
FRANK: Yeah, we got it.
BRUCE: Some things that the guys
found, it was tough to let go.
Memories kind of
kick into gear.
But I think it's gonna
go to a better place
and be used in the future.
FRANK: Bruce.
ROBBIE: Bruce.
FRANK: It was fun.
BRUCE: It's been good, guys.
FRANK: Been real fun.
Thanks for showing us around.
ROBBIE: It has.
Thanks for having us out.
BRUCE: I still have plenty
here to keep my memories going
of what went on in the past.
[honks horn]
FRANK: See ya, Bruce!
See ya, Adam!
BRUCE: We'll see you guys!
ADAM: Yep, see ya later.
FRANK: Take care now!